some of this may ring some bells from
when you've done study skills in the
past but I hope at least will be new to
you I want to teach you a little bit of
memory works this will be something that
hopefully you've heard bits off and then
or a draw in particular two really
important implications sort of
ramifications of the way that our brains
are and therefore how we need to think
about them okay so here's the lesson
okay when we think about memory memory
is a single idea it's actually got three
different parts and we've done a lot of
cognitive science to this right I'm not
sure if anyone knows what the three
parts are called - a famous one not so
much
the first kind of memory is the one that
you're all experiences right when you
sense things around you when you see and
when you hear and smell and all that
this is loaded into your brain this
second and it's kind of like has no
limit to it right you can take in it's
one of those things about why if
anyone's going to the Grand Canyon
before which I have not but you go there
and it's kind of like wow this is
amazing you can take it all in and then
when you look at photographs of it later
on you're like yeah this is it's not as
impressive because your brain can
actually handle more than a picture can
right so sensory memory is really
amazing because it's unlimited for this
strong out of time but of course it has
a big problem right what's the B problem
with this sensory memory its immediate
just kind of vanishes right we forget
most like I'm just gonna pull number out
of the air because I'm probably larger
than this but 99% of all the things you
see hear smell touch everything they
just go now quick question to you why is
this case why is our brain designed to
do this some people don't do this and
it's actually huge problem philip max
it's not useful can someone really and
on that like why is into you so I'd love
to remember everything that I ever saw
why might it be actually not useful
retain everything yeah that overload
ideas really important I don't know what
your desk at home looks like but can you
imagine what your desk would be like if
it could never forget anything if you
could never clear it away and say here I
want to do something useful right if
it's just amassed forever
it wouldn't be useful to us anymore okay
now like I said this is the memory that
not many people want to think about
because it's just kind of there the
memory that more people associated sorry
this is a bit funny is the stuff that
you actually have retained for a long
time like years and years and years okay
now just like sensory memory
this is unlimited right you can remember
some really unimportant things from a
long time ago you're like why do I still
have this migraine but it will just
stick around indefinitely here's the
trick these are not the only two
memories and that in fact these are not
the two memories that matter the most
I'd say there's one in the middle and it
has a special name I hope you know
what's it called yes that's right
so we can call it a short-term memory or
a more descriptive name is actually
working have you heard this phrase
before working memory okay now if you
haven't heard well that's okay it's
exactly what it says it's memory you
have to work on to hold in your brain
and importantly unlike your your sensory
memory and your long-term memory it's
limited in capacity its enormous
diminishment okay we generally say you
can have seven plus or minus two items
if you're really exceptional you can
hold on to nine if you're if you're a
bit of a dory maybe five or one or none
right now this is really important how
do these all fit together right well we
know that this stuff just gets forgotten
unless you pay attention to it yeah if
you think think think you can hold it in
your working memory but then how do we
get this stuff over into long-term
memory that's actually what we mean by
learning right how do you what do you
actually do to get rid of it what can
you will the repetition you think right
you get over and over and over again so
essentially we call this rehearsal right
not everything your working memory gets
retained a lot of these forgotten as
well but it all stick if you go over and
again again and again rehearsing is of
many different kinds the
sooo that really matter for us in terms
of how you learn stuff and get stuff to
stick in right is that you can either
encode which is to put stuff into brain
and importantly think about it like put
attention to it not just write it out
verbatim right you actually perhaps
think carefully or how its structured
and then put it in in a picture or a
mind map so like that and then when you
when you grab it right it's why we asked
you guys to do practice papers actually
it's like when you retrieve that
knowledge there it sort of enforces hey
this matters this is really important
keep on thinking about it right okay now
this is the basic lesson I want to give
you but the implications are the part
that matters like otherwise this is just
facts in your brain okay so let me draw
it out two really big implications that
I hope you're going to change the next
hour and fifteen minutes of your life
and then beyond okay how do we actually
remember significant amounts of things
to work on them you know that seven item
limit is like a big deal Atos that's a
small number right now the main way is
what psychologists call chunking which
is to take like separate items I mean
like group them together into single
chunks right I mean you could say this
is not a bunch of things anymore it's
one thing I can hold it in my memory now
I'm gonna illustrate this for you in a
second I'm gonna flash up twelve numbers
twelve numbers that's more than your
working memory is supposed to hold but I
ask you to try and remember them
nonetheless I'm gonna give you
they say working memory is like five to
twenty seconds I'm gonna give you eight
seconds to look at these numbers and try
and commit them Terry are you ready so
just priming you so you pay attention
here come the twelve numbers
eight seconds goes fast doesn't it boy
and you're like I don't even remember
what was in the start here but some of
you some of you are doing working really
hard some people working really hard you
still got them in your memory okay now
here's what I want to do I want to show
to you the importance of and the value
of chunking right how you can take
something like that which you're still
furiously trying to hold on to you and
despite the challenges actually remember
it now just a quick thing I want to make
sure you guys have a realistic situation
so normally you just get to spend all of
your attention remembering something
remembering something remembering
something you have to remember even
without that constant intention this is
something that I'm a guy named Herman
Ebbinghaus German psychologist really
memorable in this forgetting curve right
now have a look at this if I wanted to
make you forget those numbers all I
could have to do is wait I just wait and
the number will go right but it's worse
than that research shows that if you get
given conflicting information that's
similar right
a whole bunch of other 12 digit numbers
it becomes increasingly difficult to
grab on to that memory and the most
important thing working memory right
takes work takes effort I can completely
destroy all of your working memory by
giving you something is efficiently is
interested to grab your attention and I
don't know if you've seen this before
for me
like I can never not laugh at this like
it's just and I just watch it I feel I
feel bad for him but it's still
objectively funny okay now I'm going to
put money on the table that pretty much
everyone in the room has forgotten the
original twelve numbers that I showed
you okay maybe you're like I'm still I'm
still holding on okay now I won't test
you it's just an exercise you yourself
know whether you can remember them or
not here are the twelve now I want to
show you how chunking works it takes
something like this which sounds like it
should be very difficult especially with
all the distractions I've been giving
you and actually remember it look
closely these numbers these numbers are
actually not twelve numbers they're
actually one and maybe if I rearrange
them you'll see how these are the same
twelve numbers just reverse them
I wonder if you noticed that they're
deliberately chosen right in fact the
exact sequence of numbers you've got is
the time that this lesson began right
now when you think of this as
one object the time this lesson started
it's actually not that hard
it's how I it's one thing and not twelve
suddenly you are this is not such
challenging right you've got it in
chunks okay so there's the first
implication and we do this all the time
by the way think of something as
complicated as can you tell me what this
is it's tying your shoelaces
specifically right generally this is the
particular node people use on their
shoes right now I think we've all
forgotten because of our age how really
challenging it was to learn this the
first time and look here like that
you're like whoa this is so complicated
okay now let me try and bring it back to
us right when you look at this you've
known this formula for a good couple of
years now
do you think of this as 16 objects
that's what it is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 or do you think of it
as one when you become familiar with it
it becomes the quadratic formula right
okay so is the first implication and
it's actually the one that's sort of
been bugging me it's kind of the
principal reason why I wanted to do this
now rather than anytime I want you to
really closely about this see when you
pay close attention to something and you
think hard about it that's how you
actually retain things in memory it's
why when you're like multitask if you
like have a video on while you're like
if you're firing or the TV's on while
you're doing your homework it's sort of
mocs up this process right because what
you're encoding is not just the thing
you're thinking about it's what's around
you when you're having a conversation
with someone whilst you're doing work
you're also encoding that you don't have
a choice about this it's the way that
your brain works now right I was a admit
I showed you this picture and I wonder
if some of you wondered what it was now
in fairness I didn't show you the whole
thing which is where the lesson really
is this is the whole picture okay now
that the particular feature on a drawing
attention I'd ever guess now that I'm
show you the whole thing
it's this this brown dirty patch here do
they not know what this thing is called
it has a name dr. phrase a dirt patch
pretty close actually it illiterates
with patch this is what we call a desire
path a desire partner if anyone's heard
this phrase before designers talk about
these you see them all over right some
designer went and put in paths in this
park but valley I want people to walk
here and walk here what do people do
they're just like I can get there faster
right I'm not gonna walk all the way
here I'm not gonna walk all the way here
and then turn a Junction right I can get
there faster okay now this is the way
your brain works memory is formed the
way this desire path is formed there's
um is psychologist fu keys in the UK his
name is Dave this is the way you want to
remember something you want to retain
things in memory memory is the residue
of thought it doesn't matter how much I
tell you things if you do not think
consciously about them if you do not
guard your attention as you're working
on something when you think about that
task in front of you do you want to
remember it does this make sense